hey this is kind of interesting and i
think it's a good opportunity for an
important discussion
msnbc host joyanne reed a joyride i
guess she goes by now
on tuesday she was accused of
islamophobia
over some remarks that she made on the
monday evening program where she
kind of equated radicalized trump
supporters
to quote the way muslims act and of
course
that doesn't sound good and she is
rightly being criticized and i think
this was actually a missed opportunity
to bring something to the forefront that
is a really important discussion to have
so the setup is that they were having a
panel on her program
about president trump not denouncing
his supporters role in the via in
in being violent at protests in kenosha
and in portland and after noting how
trump
liked a tweet praising vigilante kyle
written house
and cheering pro-trump trump
demonstrators in portland
reed tried to make a point about the
president radicalizing his base and it's
sounding like
the way muslims act it doesn't sound
good and it wasn't good
take a look at the video when think when
leaders
um let's say in the muslim world talk a
lot of violent
talk and encourage their supporters to
be willing to commit violence
including on their own bodies in order
to
win against whoever they decide is the
enemy we
in the u.s media describe that as they
are radicalizing
those people particularly when they're
radicalizing young people that's how we
talk about
the way muslims act when you see what
donald trump is doing
is that any different from what we
describe
as radicalizing people i i don't believe
so
so joy reid is being rightly criticized
here because she's saying oh so all
muslims are radical she's using language
where she says
the most radical trumpists are like
muslims generally and of course that
couldn't be further from the truth
we've got over a million muslims the
overwhelming majority as we all know
are not radicals and they're not violent
and all of that stuff
but there was really an opportunity here
to have an important conversation
the conversation to be had and i would
have been
with only a slight change to wording joy
reid would have been able to do it
the conversation is extremism starts to
look the same
anytime religious fanaticism or
cult-like behavior
is at play and when you look at
right-wing christians
and the most extreme movements within
right-wing christianity
when you look at radical islamists when
you look at
trump cultists with guns they
are all very similar the cult-like
reverence to
whatever sometimes it's god sometimes
it's a religious leader sometimes it's a
cult leader sometimes it's
in the case of trump an elected official
that is a real
consideration and in fact it's part of
the conversation where when we talk
about
political violence you often see it
categorized as
right-wing violence including stuff like
militias and sovereign citizens and
white nationalists
eco-terrorism like you know the small
slice of political violence that would
be based on things like
climate defense on the left very rare
and then islamic political violence i've
made the case
for years that if you believe religion
should be the supreme law of the land
and you are willing to go and commit
violence in the name of religion
it doesn't really matter what religion
that is that's almost certainly
right-wing violence so i've been saying
for a while
radical islamic violence is right-wing
and when you look at
the precepts and the beliefs of radical
islamists and compare them to radical
christians and white nationalists who
are often influenced by
christianity they're really almost the
same
different details internally and they're
really
all right wing so i get why joy reed is
being criticized
she didn't address this the right way
she simply said this is how muslims act
which sounds like she's saying this is
how all muslims act
and it's important to remember that when
we on the left talk about this
i never say all republicans ex
all trumpists why we don't say all
muslims x
of course and the missed opportunity
here would be to say
um what we are talking about here
is that radicalism all starts to look
the same
we should be able to apply the same
language to it when we talk about
trump radicals muslim radicals or
whoever
congresswoman ilhan omar tweeted about
this saying quote
honestly this kind of casual
islamophobia
is hurtful and dangerous we deserve
better and an apology for the painful
moment for so many muslims
around our country should be forthcoming
it is hurtful and it's unproductive
but it should be okay to talk about how
all extremism starts to look very
similar
in a way that's serious and in a way
that's over sober so joy reid missed an
opportunity to say these radical
trumpists
show the same type of radicalization
that we see in all radicals
including radicalized muslims who these
radical trumpists claim to oppose
they are more similar in fact than they
would have you believe
that has to be okay to talk about i
believe that if joy reid had couched it
in those terms
it would not have gotten the backlash
that it received a radical is a radical
it doesn't matter if it's a you know
based on race color creed politics
radical is radical and it all starts to
look the same
let me know what you think i'm on
twitter at d pacman remember to get the
daily
audio podcast on spotify stitcher itunes
wherever you listen to your podcasts
if you love feeding your intellectual
curiosity but you're always
struggling to find the time check out
one of my all-time
favorite apps called blinkist blinkist
lets you consume an
entire book on your way home from work
they take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
condense each one
into text or audio that you can get
through in just 15 minutes and you get
all of the important
core ideas and information from that
book it's perfect
if you don't have enough time to do all
the reading you want to do
or if you just want to sample a book
before you buy the entire thing
i recently read a brief history of time
of course by the great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy
science they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get
twenty five percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com slash pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video